[Musique]
alors attention
première question c'est pour benjamin
castaldi benjamin castaldi
si vous répondez bien c'est très bien si
vous répondez malvois d ignorer
quelqu'un qui fera le gage à votre place
d'accord elle devra désigner très vite
eu en pleine interview à la radio
nicolas hulot a menacé de quoi de
diffuser un titre de faudel qu'on
embrasse je suis fan de lui de quitter
le studio c'est pour castaldi non ne
diffuse de chuter le studio est de
porter plainte pour diffamation ou deux
gifles et un autre invité à je crois
qu'il a mené de porter plainte pour
diffamation de porter plainte en
diffamation
car je peins sur alors nicolas hulot
c'est assez chaud sur le plateau d'on
refait le monde sur rtl avec mon ami
thomas sotto exceptionnel thomas qui
recevait nicolas hulot pour parler du
réchauffement climatique et de ses
dégâts pour la planète seront du coup
nicolas hulot était là il s'est vite
énervé contre l'une des des batteuses à
genoux ce châle manille qui contestaient
le nombre de morts provoquées par les
événements climatiques
il a menacé de quitter le studio
regardez c'est très très tard benjamin
castaldi malheureusement vous avez vous
et votre que gage dans un instant faudra
chanter ou qui avec des gros bouts de
cookies dans la bouche sais pas combien
de personnes sont tuées par les extrêmes
climatiques ce chiffre 11 mille en 2008
ils étaient 3 7 millions en 1931
vous pouvez pas dire aïssaoui s'ils y
arrivent là vous tombez dans un
négationniste parle pas du tout à l'aise
je suis animé mettant des gamins noirs
ici toujours pas ce que parce que moi
j'ai vu des victimes sur le terrain
c'est d'entendre ça je suis désolé mais
moi je ne participerai pas à une
émission où on polémique sur les
changements climatiques
je ne veux pas dans cette émission que
tout ce qui a été dit soit anéantie par
des chiffres
franchement qui n'ont absolument aucune
valeur parce qu'ils mélangent tout on va
avancer un peu dans la discussion vous
restez avec nous quand même me connais
je vous abandonne banon
mais thomas il a menacé le piteux studio
et et vénère comme un alors merci
thermique au gaz
merci benjamin castaldi deuxième
question deuxième question c'est pour
vous je vais prendre aux missionnaires
du seul maire mais me jean michel mr
question qu'a répondu laurence boccolini
un utilisateur de twitter qui écrit
qu'il adorait la voir animer le maillon
faible
moi aussi vous me manquez de mon côté
j'ai détesté
c'était l'époque où je gagnais bien ma
vie moi ce qui me manque c'est ouf avec
de la roue s'est pas lavé moi aussi vous
manqué moi aussi vous me manquez ah non
le gage se faire maquiller en 10
secondes par son voisin où la lèvre
blutch eye liner mascara vous allez
désigner quelqu'un puisque c'est la
bonne réponse by boulot ou quelqu'un qui
va se faire maquiller exactement le
boulot regardez laurence boccolini ce
qu'elle a dit regardez voilà l a dit moi
aussi vous me manquez donc tout le monde
a dit est ce que vous êtes plutôt aller
money drop parce que le maillon faible
c'était c'était très dur très dur à
faire physiquement
ouais c'est vrai pour moi parce que l'on
tournait je commençais à 8 heures du
matin je finisse à 21h
etes-vous pendant 10 heures à ce voyage
et surtout c'est que je devenu une
caricature de moi même et c'est quelque
chose que je ne referai jamais jamais le
maillon faible aura dû revenir à
l'antenne c'est une caricature après ces
sas est revenu sur des huit années oui
mais ça peut pas revenir dans la déconne
c'est pas pour déconner ce jeu le mal en
fait
coli elle m'a un peu énervé je vous lis
pascal a taclé le maillon faible de ces
huit avec julien courbet alors que
julien était formidable dedans voilà
elle a profité pour glisser un petit
tacle dans le boss du figaro regardez
dans les livres pour enfants quelle
gentille éléphant et le roi de céleste
ville d'agde au bar pour changer une
roue quel appareil actionne ton avec un
levier pour soulever la voiture
c'est 1,1 sous le verre c'est un cric
quel nom donne ton à la femelle du singe
quel que soit son espèce
la singette non la guenon sophie quel
film d'olivier marchal a pour titre
l'adresse parisienne de la police
judiciaire 25 et des orphelins ils ont
déménagé son taux 36 maintenant des
maillons fait alors que je suis dacc est
parfait voilà l des fouets violence à la
des petits enfants reprend vite elle se
reprend vite mais voilà alors vous soyez
j'aimerais bien que sophie salissent un
peu benjamin alors allez-y matière vous
avez 10 secondes à l'essai ou plaqué
souffre question suivante la question
suivante pour calibrer novelli question
alors je vous le dis si vous perdez le
gage s'est envoyé un sms à une personne
avec la phrase c'est on appelle un texte
ouf
tu veux voir ma tout en acquiert une
personne de votre répertoire que je
choisir yeux
l événement très attendu a démarré à
paris une ligne de métro sans grève le
festival de la gastronomie
le salon de l'auto la fashion week end
la fashion week c'est ce que vous auriez
dit amel les mesfiouis la fois sur wii
c'est une bonne réponse est oui la
fashion week masculine ait dit non si
c'est vrai que c'est un événement dans
le monde de la mode qui attire beaucoup
même match a duré six jours et il faut
savoir qu'il n'ya plus de cinquante
créateurs
donc c'est assez gros alors vous le
savez à eau vous voulez ses pairs castel
suffit donc peut-être la rue dictature
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes beaucoup sur regard délavé la
fashion-week parce que les looks sont
très très drôle on vous a fait une
petite copine détenus les plus goûteux
et kelly bien entendu toujours dit c'est
qui pour envoyer merci on avait compté
belloni on y va c'est pas crédible
[Musique]
c'est alors le il avait levé à envoyer à
yves calvi oui son collègue et
patrouille avait manuel tuft quoi tu la
veux ma grosse non tu veux voir ma
grosse borne à citer entorse à sorède tu
veux voir ma grosse tous pu envoyer des
mots nous dit quand c'est fait attention
aux questions suivantes question
suivante
tout vient de déclarer jeu qui vient de
déclarer qu'il vient de déclarer je n'ai
pas senti la justice faire son travail
patrick balkany julien lepers d'aix où
carlos ghosn ça tue l'info média
également ses amis ça rit c'est pour
gilles verdez mon chien alors je connais
la réponse c'est julien lepers et bien
une fois de plus vous êtes excellent
profil puisque c'est aix et oui texte
je vous le dis le 3 décembre dernier la
cour d'appel de paris a confirmé le
licenciement de texte pour faute grave
après sa blague racontée sur ces 8
ces indices à la demande d'indemnités à
hauteur de 1 2 million d'euros a été
rejetée
et pour la première fois il a réagi à
cette décision
regardez-la réagi pour la première fois
c'était au micro de non-stop people chez
note jean marc morandini regarde s'il
particulièrement injuste mais je vais je
peux pas me plaindre parce qu'il ya des
tas de gens qui sont dans la rue avec
des gilets jaunes avec des tas d'idées
avec des beaucoup de pauvreté donc qu'il
hors de question de se plaindre j'ai
surtout senti que la justice s'est pas
sentie trahie elle fait à cesser
complètement la décision est
complètement incroyable mais je ne veux
pas la commenter plus que ça voilà donc
mais c'est inévitablement très injuste
va
un an
nous avons envoyé oui c'est vrai je vois
matoub bravo usa bravo isa gilbert des
âmes et la mauvaise réponse il faut vous
faire une moustache avec de la moutarde
de dijon
merci à quoi vous en avez vous fait une
moustache merci pas me voilà à quoi ça
va ça va piquer un peu c'est rien du
tout je les ai déjà fait à la maison
pour mes amis
attention les chéris question pour vous
géraldine maillet ah merde
jq afin classement des vins français les
plus drôles de l'année
selon vous qui est le premier benjamin
tranier haroun jérôme commandeur et là
où l'audience de karine le marchand
entre eux et jérôme commandeur
mais je dirais non
c'est jean jamin tranier quel français
bureau l'année et je suis d'accord avec
eux qui jean bazin tranier qui est
exceptionnel bajard entre amis qui sera
avec moi dans la grosse rigolade la
prochaine de la semaine prochaine car
c'est le plus drôle moi aussi pour moi
de l'année 2020 chez vous le présentez
il est exceptionnel par vers matane et
je vous en ai parlé à certains ici pour
moi c'est le plus drôle de l'année oui
jean michel et on voudrait aussi vous
avez fait une entrée fracassante dans
classe penchent tous classés numéro 15
c'est vrai mercian voilà vous auriez pu
être mieux mais c'est comme ça ils ont
écrit c'est quoi qu'on en dise l'un des
meilleurs valeur de sa génération et il
un sens de la répartie incroyable je
souscris totalement et à notre ami
fabrice éboué que j'adore qui est 12e
haroun qui est très fort aussi 17e marie
papillon très forte 6/18 voilà et c'est
vrai que c'était très heureux de ma
quinzième place par une ode gestion
[Applaudissements]
fracas souvent s'il hanouna je le dis et
je le prends très bien à chaque fois 10
équipes à ce que des coups mais un
second degré c'est comme nous quand on
va ns voilà c'est on va nous on essaie
de rigoler voilà c'est on comprend et
même quand on fracasse cello je le
comprends et ça me fait ça me fait bien
rire voilà en tout cas je suis très très
heureux de ma quinzième place ça m'a
beaucoup touché